[تصفيق]
قتل كل ما يمت للحياه بالصله وقطع كل امل
في النجاه والتفكير فقط بمغادره بيتك
ومنطقتك سياسه اباده انتهجتها اسرائيل ظنا
ان ذلك سيفرغ شمال غزه من اهله
الفلسطينيين وساكنيه وقد بقي وفق بلديه
غزه اكثر من 700 الف منهم في شمال القطاع
الاكثر استهدافا منذ بدايه
الحرب كرر الجيش الاسرائيلي دعوته ان
عليكم بالتوجه جنوبا حيث الامان كان ذلك
ادعائه منذ اليوم الاول للحرب فحتى
النازحون وهم يشقون مسارات قالت اسرائيل
انها امنه قصفوا خلال نزوحهم فسقط منهم
شهداء ظن الناس ان الاحتماء بمؤسسات
تعليميه تتبع وكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
وهي ترفع علم الامم المتحده سيجعلهم في
مامن لكنهم قصفوا واستهدفوا لا الفخوره
وهي تقصف مرتين خلال هذه الحرب حمتهم ولا
مدارس اخرى في الوسط والجنوب فعلت الامر
نفسه لجا الالاف الى المستشفيات ومجرد نطق
اسمها يحيلك الى انها وجدت لتنقذ الارواح
وتبعث الحياه وتعالج المرضى والجرحى
واستهدافها اقرب للمحرمات وفق القانون
الدولي الانساني لكن في غزه لا خطوط حمراء
امام اسرائيل قصفت اسرائيل المستشفى
المعمداني فعج ساحته بمئات جثه الشهداء من
الاطفال والنساء وحصر وقصف مستشفى
الشفاء تداول العالم صور اطفال خدج من
داخل المستشفى وقد حرموا العنايه اللازمه
بسبب حصار الشفاء لجات اسرائيل لاحقا
لترحيل القصري نحو جنوب غزه لعدد كبير ممن
كانوا في الشفاء رحله عبور ماساويه امتدت
لكيلومترات عديده قطعها جرحى وكبار سن
واطفال ونساء مشيا على الاقدام دمرت قوات
الاحتلال لاحقا مرافق المستشفى وبنيته
التحتيه الاساسيه قبل انسحابها ولم تكن
قصه الشفاء سوى امتداد لسرد اسرائيليه
اخرى بشان مستشفى رنتيسي مع الايام بدا
واضحا الاستهداف الممنهج للمستشفيات
والمنشات الطبيه ورغم قتامه المشهد اثارت
الطواقم الطبيه التزاما بواجبهم الاخلاقي
على البقاء مع المرضى والنازحين لان نبض
اي مستشفى بالحياه سيعني استمرار صمود
الناس حيث ما يعيشون واتقى الصحفيون كما
هو الحال هنا بمستشفى الاندونيسي شمالي
غزه حجم الدمار الذي لحقه وكان مصيره اشبه
بالشفاء حصارا
واستهدافاً قطاع غزه هدفا متكررا منذ
بدايه الحرب للقصف المدفعي والجوي ويكفي
ان تشاهد هذه الخريطه التي تضهر الحجم
التراكميه للدمار خصوصا في الشمال نحو 40
ال طن من المتفجرات القتها قوات الاحتلال
على القطاع منذ بدايه الحرب وفق المكتب
الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه اما نيويورك
تايمز فنقلت عن مسؤول عسكري امريكي ان نحو
90% من الذخائر التي القتها اسرائيل على
غزه في الاسبوعين الاولين كان قنابل
مواجهه بالاقمار الصناعيه تزن الوحيده
منها بين 1000 و000 رطل ووفق الصحيفه
استخدمت اسرائيل ما لا يقل عن قنبلتين
وزنهما الف رطل خلال غاره جويه نهايه
اكتوبر الماضي على مخيم جباليا جعل غزه
غير صالحه للعيش هكذا تريد اسرائيل وايام
الهدنه المؤقته كشفت حجم الدمار الكبير في
البنيه التحتيه والمنازل هذه صور تظهر حجم
الدمار الذي لحق بمنطقه بيت لاهيه شمالي
القطاع وهنا دمار مماثل في منطقه ابرج
الندى في الشمال وفي مدينه غزه وتحديدا في
مخيم الشاطئ يتكرر المشهد من حيث اثار
القصف والتدمير وبحي الناصر ومحيط مستشفى
رنتيسي صور دمار مماثله وقد مسحت مربعات
سكنيه باكملها وحتى حينما يبادر الناس
للوصول من جنوب القطاع الى شماله لتفقد
منازلهم ان بقيت كحال هؤلاء في بيت حنون
يقابلهم جيش الاحتلال بالرصاص لمنعهم من
الاقتراب تحت كل هذا الركام دفن مئات من
الشهداء في اماكن استشهادهم وبقيت جثتهم
تحت الانقاض ترتفع مطالبات بتوفير معدات
اكبر لرفع هذه الانقاض والبحث عن
المفقودين تلك قصه تدمير اسرائيلي ممنهج
لكن من فوق الركام رساله فلسطيني من اهل
غزه باذن الله احنا ضاين في المكان هذا
حتى لو بدي ابني خيمه عندي ه بدي اضل هنا